hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice puzzle I found while while browsing
Twitter as I usually do was posted by uh
justify on Twitter and it's uh well it's
just a wonderful wonderful puzzle to
start your day and the week as today is
a Monday uh so this is the position uh I
don't know who the who made the puzzle
or does the puzzle have any sort of a
history or something uh so I decided to
have Mr hudigai have the white pieces
here and myself as the wielder of the
black pieces as white is the one that
wins this game but white has to be very
very precise this black is of material
you can see that black is of the
exchange and also black is up to ponzo
uh White has to be uh very very precise
in order to actually pull this off so
this is the position it's a beautiful
beautiful one your friends at the bar in
the library will will uh love you after
you show this to them so uh you know
have at it have a few seconds or pause
the video you know come back later or
you know save it for later come back
tomorrow but you will you will really
enjoy once you crack this one so I have
at it I I will give you a few seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
beautiful queen plus Rook sacrifice
combo and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show we start with uh Queen
uh sorry not with Queen yeah with Queen
to A5 with check not something that you
would expect but before I show this I
just want to show you what happens if
you let's say okay you want to prepare
Checkmate Rook H7 you cut off the black
king and now you're preparing Queen K1
Checkmate uh once Queen to d8 displayed
the Checkmate is gone and now black is
just better once you play Queen A1 check
Queen A5 defends the check and now there
is no more way for you to actually win
the game you're just down material so
the move you really had to find is this
beautiful queen to A5 with check we can
do it once again in slow motion uh if
you go up the board King B7 then Queen
to B6 is Checkmate so your only option
is to capture the queen queen captures
Queen on A5 and now look at this another
slow motion move Rook to A4 check
now the black king has only one uh one
legal move and it's not even a move with
the King you have to play B captures on
A4 and now I'm sure you guys even if you
haven't seen the puzzle now you know
what's coming B captures an A4 only move
and now the only move that wins for
white and it's a move that more often
than not when this game is for white and
that is Pawn to B4 Pawn to B for his
Checkmate here as the king covers the B6
square and the bishop controls the light
squares so the black king has nowhere to
go uh so truly a a spectacular puzzle I
haven't we've seen similar ones but not
the one uh uh quite like this where you
can sacrifice a queen and the rook and
then deliver a mate with a pawn and not
just any pawn pawn to B4 which is very
very special we can show once again
Queen A5 check King captures Rook day
for checkpoint captures and now Pawn to
B for checkmate uh that's it that's the
puzzle hope you guys enjoyed it I found
a great joy once I saw it on on Twitter
yesterday so I thought you guys might
enjoy this as well you say I know a lot
of you guys aren't on Twitter
for some reason uh
I don't know why I I think it's a lovely
platform once you are able to uh you
know if you follow only only the things
that you yourself are interested in and
you don't uh uh succumb to you know ads
or spam or something like that you know
you can really uh follow what what
interests you like I'm interested in in
chess and some other stuff and I only
followed that on Twitter so I don't know
I I just think it's a it's a it's a
lovely platform to uh to enjoy and also
you can find so much stuff about the
chess there like everyone posts stuff
about Chess there now I don't know I
thought you guys might be interested in
that uh but yeah that's the puzzle hope
you guys enjoyed it and that you were
able to solve it I know you saw that
before move even before the queen
sacrifice you probably wouldn't even
start the puzzle with B4 as did I uh but
unfortunately it only ends with B4 but
what are you gonna do uh so yeah that's
the puzzle hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank Richard Schwartz uh
Jonathan Bradley Christopher Norris
mocosoft and Mikhail arboy for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions checking Twitter
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World today a big big tournament is
starting up so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day